ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON. SELLER
ADAM GRAY CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY GEO
COMMITTEE I WELCOME EVERYONE TO
TODAY'S HEARING THE TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACT BEFORE US
TODAY. IS ONE WHICH WAS
EXECUTED AUGUST TWENTY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN BETWEEN
GOVERNOR SOME OF THE HALF OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CAVS ON BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
TODAY WILL HEAR OF THE
PRINCIPAL ARCHITECTS. OF THAT
COMPACT IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
CHAIR PERSON OF THE TRIBE OR
REPRESENTED ABOVE I AM PLEASED
TO SEE THAT THIS COMPACT
THERE'S MANY THE GREAT RECENT.
ACTS OF COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE DRAMA
PROTECTIONS MITIGATING OFF
RESERVATION IMPACTS LABOR
PROVISIONS ETCETERA. I KNOW
MEMBERS AS COMEDIAN THERE'S
LESS APPRECIATE DEMONSTRATIONS
COMMITMENT TO MAKING SURE THESE
PROVISIONS ARE NEGOTIATED A
SOMEWHAT CONSISTENT IN A
COMPACT WHILE STILL. RESPECTING
EAT THE INDIVIDUALITY OF EACH
COMPACT THAT COMES BEFORE US
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE AS A
WHOLE IT SHOWS WE POINT OUT
THIS COMPACT REFLECTS CONTINUED
COMMITMENTS BY THE TRIBE
REVENUE SHARING WITH NON GAMING
AND LIMITED GAMING TRIBES SO
THAT THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF
GAMING. REACH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I JUST WANNA REMIND ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES NO FORMAL
VOTE WILL BE TAKEN TODAY.
TODAY'S HEARING IS FOR THE
COMMITTEE BE BRIEFED ON THE
CONTENTS OF THE COMPACT. REVIEW
THOSE WILL LOOK FORWARD TO A
VOTE ON THE ASSEMBLY FOR BY THE
ENTIRE BODY IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE BY SELLER
MEDORA GARCIA. IS THE
RATIFICATION BILL FOR THIS
COMPACT. ON A PERSONAL NOTE
WE'D LIKE TO BOTH WELCOME
INTAKE MISS AND A MARK ON HER
FIRST COMPACT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH HER AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THESE ISSUES
GOING FORWARD SO WELCOME. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU WOULD ALL
PROCEED UP TO THE DíAS AND
BEGIN THE PRESENTATION. MR
GARCIA AS A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD YOU LIKE TO AYE
HANDLES THE PRIVILEGE OF MAKING
THE OPENING REMARKS ON YOUR
BILL. I SURE MISSION SURE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR. THIS
INFORMATION HEARING IT'S A
GREAT PLEASURE TO. HAVE THE
CAPS ON BAND MISSION INDIANS.
Là REPRESENTED HERE TODAY BY
THEIR VICE CHAU CHAIR AND THEIR
TEAM TRAVELING ALL THE WAY FROM
THE- FIFTY SIX ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY THAT IT'S A-
TRULY GREAT HONOR TO BE ABLE TO
REPRESENT THIS. TRIBE AS I
MENTIONED IN THE SENATE G. O.
THAT THIS TRIBE. IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC DRIVER IN
OUR DISTRICT. AND ALSO A GOOD
COMMUNITY PARTNER. IT ALSO IS
IMPORTANT. TO NOTE THAT IT
COVERS ON BàN MISSION INDIANS.
ARE REALLY WHO LED THE WAY FOR
INDIAN GAMING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY NOW VIA. NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN A DECISION BY THE-
SUPREME COURT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND SO THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT. WITH
THEM IN THE WRONG Là TRIBE
TEAMED UP TO ENSURE. THAT THE
SOVEREIGN RIGHT OF INDIAN
GAMING WOULD BE FOR A FIGHT
AGAINST. STATE SO WITH THAT IS
A GERMAN THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HAVING THIS INFORMATION HEARING
AND YOU'LL BACK BECAUSE THE
FORTY. THANK YOU MR GARCIA AT
THIS TIME WILL GO AHEAD AND
HEAR FROM OUR- MISS NAY BURKE
ON BEHALF OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN GRAY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS ANNA NAY
MARK AND I AM THE GOVERNOR'S
TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS ADVISER.
IVAN THE STATE ENTERED INTO A
TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACTS IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHICH
ENABLED THE TRIBE THROUGH
REVENUES GENERATED BY ITS
CASINO TO SUPPORT A STRONG AND
SELF SUFFICIENT TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT AND TO FIND
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES
FOR ITS CITIZENS. IN LIGHT OF
THE UPCOMING EXPIRATION OF THAT
COMPACT THE NEWSMEN
MINISTRATION NEGOTIATED AND
SIGNED A NEW CONTRACT WITH THE
CABAZON BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS. THIS IS THE FIRST
COMPACT AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
NEGOTIATED TO COMPLETION. THE
ECONOMIC PROVISIONS SEEK TO
PROVIDE TEMPORARY FINANCIAL
RELIEF FOR THE TRIBE WILL THEY
PAY DOWN THEIR OUTSTANDING DEBT
TO ENSURE THE TRIBE IS THE
PRIMARY BENEFICIARY OF THE
FACILITY. AS INTENDED BY THE
INDIAN GAMING REGULATORY ACT.
THIS RELIEF IS ACHIEVED BY
USING A FLAT RATE PAYMENT FOR
REVENUE SHARING WITH LIMITED OR
NON GAMING TRIBES AMOUNTING TO
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. CABS ON
WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE A FLAT
CREDIT AMOUNT AGAINST PAYMENT
OF A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. DURING HIS
RELIEF AT THE NUMBER OF TRIBES
DEVICES. WILL BE TO EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED WILL PAY PRO RATA
REGULAR. BEGINNING IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE TRIBES
REVENUE SHARING PAYMENTS WILL
CHANGE AS THEIR NUMBER. SOME
DEVICES INCREASES. THEIR NUMBER
OF DEVICES WILL INCREASE TO TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
AND THEY WILL PAY FOUR POINT
TWO FIVE EIGHT. ERCENT GROSS
GAMING REVENUE FROM THE
OPERATION OF GAS PRICES OVER
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY TOWARDS
REVENUE SHARING. THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO TAKE UP TO FIFTY FIVE
CENT CREDIT SICK THIS PAYMENT.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO PAY PRO
RATA REGULATORY COSTS. THE
OTHER CORPORATE VISIONS OF THIS
COMPACT INCLUDING TERMS REALLY
LICENSING REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION OR
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO
COMPAQ'S RATIFIED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THIS IS STILL STANGEL
SIMILARITY INCLUDES PROTECTIONS
AGAINST WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT.
PROVISIONS TO ADOPTING COMPLY
WITH THE FEDERAL FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT INCLUSION OF THE
STATE'S MINIMUM WAGE RATES. THE
TRIBAL ADOPT THE STANDARD
TRIBAL LABOR SHINS ORDINANCE.
THE CARD ALSO. TO TIER
PROVISION FOR AN MENTAL.
SHINNING VINCE. COMP WHICH
ALLOWS FOR A BURLESQUE TEND TO
PROCESS DEPENDING ON WHETHER
THE TRIBE OPERATES OVER UNDER
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY DEVICES.
BOTH OF THESE REQUIRE THAT. ANY
PROJECT THE TRIBE MUST ALLIES
IN DOCUMENT PRESERVATION
IMPACT. PROVIDE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD. CAN COME TO ME
GREEN WITH A STAKE OUT. THANK
YOU AND TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND SAVE
OUR QUESTIONS AFTER THAT HAS
INCLUDED AT THIS TIME WILL GO
AHEAD HERE FROM MY THE
HONORABLE ALEXIS NICKLES
LIAISON TO THE GENERAL COUNSEL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS ALEXIS NICHOLS I AM
THE LIAISON TO GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR THE CABINS ON END OF
MISSION INDIANS AND I'VE HELD
THIS POSITION. SENSE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE I DO REMEMBER
BOTH OF MY PARENTS WORKING ON
THE NINETY NINE CONTACTS AND
I'M IT IS ABSOLUTELY MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TO
REPRESENT MY TRIED AND HAMLEY
TODAY. ALSO HERE TO REPRESENT
THE TRIBE OR MISTER PAUL SAMA
DIRECTOR OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS. AND
JOE YOU COULD I DIRECTOR OF
PLANTS. THE CONTACT THAT IS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
REPRESENTS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF WORK BY BOTH STATE AND
TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES. WE
BEGAN THESE NEGOTIATIONS
SEVERAL YEARS AGO DURING THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION AND
COMPLETED THE PROCESS LESS THAN
TWO WEEKS AGO UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF GOVERNOR NEW
STUFF. I AM THE TRIBE WANT TO
THANK MISS NAY MARK AND HER
STAFF ARE DEVOTING THE TIME AND
ENERGY TO LISTEN AND HEAR OUR
CONCERNS AND THEN TO HELP US A
SIX SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE THIS
PROCESS. GAMING HAS BEEN A KEY
TO THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF
THE CABAZON BAND WELL WE HAVE
COME A LONG WAY IN THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS WE STILL HAVE MUCH
TO DO. IN THIS NEW CONTACT. US
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS. SERVICES
AND BENEFITS TO OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY. WELL AT
THE SAME TIME THE COMPACT
REVISED BENEFITS AND
PROTECTIONS TO OUR EMPLOYEES.
OUR CUSTOMERS INTO THE LARGER
COACHELLA VALLEY COMMUNITY. FOR
THESE REASONS WE WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
TO APPROVE THIS NEW TRIBAL
STATE COMPACT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO OUR
THIRD PRESENTER ON THE PANEL
AND ASK. JACK GRUBER IN OR
PERHAPS SHAMED GROUPS WILL BE
IS ABSENCE TO. PRESENT THE
LABOR POSITION. THE COMPACT
REFORMERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF
UNITED HERE PENSION IN FOR JACK
RUBIN WHO UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO
BE TRAVELING TODAY HE SENT HIS
APOLOGIES IF YOU WERE HERE HE
WOULD TELL YOU THAT HE IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND THE
UNION ESUPPORT OF THE SENATE
THANKS THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
THE TRIBE FOR. CONTINUING WITH
THE RECENT. PRESS. TAX THAT.
BOTH REDUCE REVENUE OBLIGATIONS
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS OF THE
TRIED TO THE STATE BUT ALSO.
ENHANCE WORKER RIGHTS TO
ORGANIZE AND JOIN A UNION SO WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT
AND WE SUPPORT THIS. OKAY AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO. BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE FOR
THE PANEL. SEEING NONE AT THIS
TIME CONGRATULATIONS. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION WILL
BE LOOK FORWARD TO AS I SAID IN
MY OPENING REMARKS TO A
PRESENTATION ON THE ASSEMBLY
FOR THE NEAR FUTURE. BEFORE WE
CONCLUDE WE WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE COME
BACK PLEASE. APPROACH AND NINE.
IS THAT YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME IN HEARING
THE COMPACT SUSAN JOHNSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NATION'S INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
IN ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. SEEING NONE THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS DAY AND
THE COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED